what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk about marvel and all things mcu
and today we have our first
look at the official miss marvel suit
yes we've seen photos of her in a suit
before but that is the suit that she
made on her own this
is an official suit and probably the
final suit that she'll wear in the
series but we'll talk about that in just
a bit
first big shout out to everybody who
showed up at the live stream yesterday
just so you know we did announce the
giveaway winner it was teague
tozier he's already been notified and it
looks like the next giveaway is going to
be
a stormbreaker marvel legends giveaway
so be sure to subscribe to my channel
and cosmic culture for your chance to
enter we have some other really cool
giveaways coming up too
so it seems like marvel kind of has a
trend going on here and that is the
trend of one
comic accurate suits but two the heroes
not getting these comic accurate suits
until the very
very end of their shows wanda didn't get
her true scarlet witch
comic accurate costume until the finale
of one division
falcon didn't get his comic accurate
captain america suit until the very end
of the falcon and the winter soldier and
now it's looking like that's probably
going to be the case for kamala khan and
miss marvel here is the first look at
kamala khan as
miss marvel in her comic accurate suit
and as you can see here
it is pretty dang comic accurate she's
got the red and blue with the red
spandex underneath
she has the lightning bolt on her shirt
and it looks like she's wearing a red
scarf which is what miss marvel wears
she doesn't actually wear a cape it's a
scarf
and of course she wears the mask on her
face that totally disguises her so
nobody can recognize her at all
superhero logic for sure
and she has the golden bracelet on her
left wrist now the only thing that's
really missing here is her blue boots
and it looks like that's just kind of a
creative choice that they're going with
here it clearly seems like she's wearing
converse here and that's probably just a
creative decision that's probably what
kamala wears
most of the time in the series so she
most likely just decided to keep the
shoes
now the reason i say that she probably
won't get the costume until the very end
is one because like i mentioned in the
beginning
that's what happened with wanda and
falcon but two we have seen
a makeshift costume that she has made
herself in previous leaked photos
now this costume was designed after her
idol
captain marvel as you can see here it
pretty much looks just like captain
marvel suit and a lot of people thought
that this could be
for like a halloween costume or
something like that but in these photos
we see other people around her
and her friends are not wearing costumes
now she most likely made this costume
before she got powers but this
is probably the costume she's going to
originally wear
when she gets her powers and it's
probably not going to last very long i
wouldn't be surprised if we actually see
another costume in between these two
that we've already seen
miss marvel slash kamala khan's super
powers are essentially shape-shifting
she
can lengthen her limbs change the shape
and size of her entire body and alter
her overall appearance
and that does include kind of
shape-shifting to look like other people
although those are her comic superpowers
and we're not too sure on what marvel
has planned for her
mcu super powers because as we know they
sometimes
change them but no doubt she'll
definitely have the power to lengthen
her limbs which is why i think that
first costume isn't going to last very
long i think she's going to go and
lengthen her limbs and it's pretty much
going to rip
then perhaps we'll see another costume
and then by the end we'll see
this costume and in the scene right here
we can actually see her kind of step
into
a active crime scene we have police
barricades and the police are holding
people back
we can kind of see some people in the
background look at what's happening in
terror
it looks like somebody is in distress
but kamala is walking up like it's no
big deal at all and this will probably
be a pretty cool scene where she first
shows the world her powers now it's
unclear whether or not marvel is
actually going to make her an
inhuman or if they're going to give her
her powers another way
but that's a story that we have to look
forward to when miss marvel finally
comes out
in the meantime be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news and let me know what you think
about miss marvel's costume
in the comments down below and be sure
to let me know which marvel phase 4
project you're most excited about
in the comments don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram or twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof